from on high the helicopters descended
to collect the remains of Francisco
Franco in life he was known for his
ironclad rule who saw his own leadership
as a Catholic crusade in death he became
a relic of autocracy a figure of times
past and a reminder of a troubling era
it was a monument to a man who dominated
twentieth century Spain built on a site
that holds one of the biggest mass
graves in Europe it became known as the
valley of the Fallen constructed by the
forced labor of political prisoners at
the time
Franco's family had resisted the Spanish
government's decision to move his coffin
but despite the pressure from right-wing
groups Spain Supreme Court ruled that
the exclamation had to go ahead
i fear most' regimen it took a lot to
get rid of a repressive regime with his
tightness almost as long to get rid of
its artifice of public homage there is
room for all kinds of opinions on when
to carry this out each one with its own
criteria the government of Spain
announced it would do it in the moment
it was possible to do so this is a time
and so the remains of Francisco Franco
arrived at the cemetery
the exclamation a symbolic end of his
dictatorship and the end of Spain's
transition to democracy but even 44
years after his death there are still
repercussions being felt the decision to
remove the remains provoked a furious
reaction from Franco's family and a
reluctance to accept why for so many of
the victims families it was a chance to
turn the page in Spain's history well
you know all the victims and our victims
and their victims on both sides and
we've tried to put this in our past and
we have not been able to because of this
new present we had put this thing behind
us few of the political prisoners forced
to build the complex at the valley of
the Fallen are still alive Nicolas
Sanchez albertov was one of the only two
who managed to escape the prison there
his hope that it can be transformed into
a place of reconciliation it opens
possibility
for having more decent life in Spain and
more decent democracy because democracy
up to now has been tainted by all these
problems the memories of this turbulent
time are never far behind but the
exclamation with all its complexities
may help to reconcile Spain's torment
from this era
Sonia a go al Jazeera el pardo Madrid